RECORDING: Laurel.
Laurel.
DANA BOEBINGER: Laurel.
KEVIN SITEK: Yanny.
DANA BOEBINGER: It
just, it is Laurel.
KEVIN SITEK: I've
listened to this
like so many different ways, and
all I can ever hear is Yanny.
DANA BOEBINGER: So this is kind
of like the auditory version
of the dress that we
saw a few years ago
on the internet, in that it's
a physical stimulus that's
out there, and it's
kind of ambiguous.
And depending on how
the brain is choosing
to interpret the signal,
you're going to perceive it
in a totally different way.
So here we're looking
at a spectrogram
of the auditory illusion itself,
the Laurel or Yanny word.
And what we're
actually seeing is
that on the x-axis in the
horizontal direction is time.
And then the y-axis
is the frequency.
So low at bottom
and high at the top,
and you can see that well it
sounds like a voice might only
be one pitch, There's
actually a whole bunch
of different frequencies
included in that speech sound.
KEVIN SITEK: There's a
big gap on the lower side.
It's not white, so there's
definitely some energy there,
some acoustic energy.
And so what could be
happening is that people who
hear Laurel are actually
putting another line
through that space, whereas
people who hear Yanny,
they're going to
say that whatever
is in between the two really
dark bands is actually just
like noise.
DANA BOEBINGER:
Yeah, so it all has
to do with what frequencies
your brain is assigning
are important for figuring
out which speech sound it is.
KEVIN SITEK: So
like this is what
it sounds like if you cut
out the high frequencies
and only have the
low frequencies.
RECORDING: Laurel.
KEVIN SITEK: I even hear Laurel.
INTERVIEWER: I heard Laurel.
DANA BOEBINGER:
Yeah, that's Laurel.
INTERVIEWER: That's Laurel.
KEVIN SITEK: Definitely.
And if you cut out the low
frequencies and you only
have the high frequencies--
RECORDING: Yanny.
KEVIN SITEK: Is that Yanny?
DANA BOEBINGER: That's Yanny.
KEVIN SITEK: The same
acoustic information
is hitting everyone's ears.
But the brain is then going
to interpret that differently.
So that's based on
the brain's experience
with bad phone speakers, based
on the brain's experience
with this language,
and also, for instance,
some people with high
frequency hearing loss,
like as people get
older, you tend
to lose some of the
highest frequencies.
Yeah I think it's probably
good to have some friends
on the Laurel side, just to--
DANA BOEBINGER: That's
right, we all need
friends in Laurel places.
[LAUGHS]